ce restaurant est l'une des institutions
du prêcheur construit lie à 20 en bord
de mer il est géré depuis 2004 par marie
claude et son conjoint
toute l'année on y sert la cuisine du
pays j'ai déjà commencé à préparer
ravoux de gabri il mijote
et puis là maintenant après je vais
faire une fricassée des produits j'avais
fait aussi en colombe d'euros car les
recettes de la maison ne sont pas les
seules raisons de son succès
l'établissement bercé par les vagues aux
freins point de vue idyllique mais avec
le changement climatique et la montée
des eaux
la mère justement s'invite un peu trop
près depuis 15 ans la mer entrée
vraiment 60 m vous êtes installé juste
c'est pour vous donner un niveau à peu
près à la deuxième banque même si a pas
de tempête vous êtes sur le qui vive
tout tend toujours à l'inquiétude
d'aujourd'hui avec ça du moment qu'il ya
une montée des eaux qu'ils annoncent un
peu d'eau un peu de grosses vagues on
est forcé de le plus souvent ne pas
dormir quatre cinq fois dans l'année
tout déménagé rom est et sera de
toujours perdre deux-trois jours dans la
semaine quoi ces restaurateurs ont dû
faire réaliser un enrochement pour se
protéger et sollicite aujourd'hui la ctm
pour récupérer des roches de la rivière
jusqu'au passage de dean en 2007
le restaurant était assuré depuis
l'assureur s'est retirée et les seules
propositions dépasserait 5000 euros
désormais en ce moment je n'ai que la
responsabilité civile
donc mon fonds de commerce nier le
bâtiment n'est pas assurée donc je
recherche je suis toujours à la
recherche d'un assureur je risque à tout
moment quand ils ne roulent ou et un
cyclone de perdre complètement
mon entreprise le restaurant de 250
couverts on prend en ce moment cinq
salariés et ne ferme jamais pour
compenser les périodes de gros temps
malgré tout les propriétaires savent
qu'ils vont d'un jour déplacer leurs
activités vers les hauteurs la ville du
prêcheur mène d'ailleurs cette réflexion
avec tous les riverains un groupe
d'architectes un nouvel aménagement de
la ville devra s'organiser ou du bourg
on est en pleine réflexion
on envisage à long terme de déménager
avec un gros coeur bien sûr on va pas
retrouver un site tel que le melody mais
on sera obligé
de partir un jour ou l'autre j'espère
que ce sera le plus tard possible
ici le couple investit des centaines de
milliers d'euros alors avant ce jour
fatidique où il faudra bien faire ses
valises la question se pose du
dédommagement
comme pour tous les entrepreneurs et les
particuliers menacées dans le monde par
la montée des eaux